Blissful smokes I bet you this is hella
cool I'll do it no you don't have to hit
it I'm just gonna box the room oh you're
boxing the room yeah oh my God yes I
thought you were gonna spray that [__]
in my face that's what she said
it's a crazy pause
hey yo my bad that was insane you ever
wonder like do I smoke too much weed and
then and then this [__] happens around
you and you're like oh yeah for sure
that's me yeah I smoke a lot there we go
this is insane
holy [__]
yeah this guy's really got the [__]
weed blicky
that's crazy what the [__] it's coming
to push trees very soon
[Music]
that [__] looks crazy you hear it
that's why it is sick I need these when
I'm walking in this is my WWF [__]
intro right here
thank you